[موسيقى]
اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من القدس مرحبا بكم
ثلاثه اسابيع على حرب اسرائيل على غزه
موجه جديده من الغارات الاسرائيليه على
شمال غرب القطاع وجباليا والشجاع وبيت
حنون وقالت وزاره الصحه بغزه ان الاحتلال
ارتكب 41 مجزره راح ضحيتها اكثر من 200
شهيد في حين تجاوز عدد ضحايا العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه السب 300 شهيد ونحو 19
الف
مصاب سته جرحى في قصف صاروخي جديد على تل
ابيب وكتائب القسام تعلن مسؤوليتها وتقول
بان القصف هو رد على المجازر الاسرائيليه
بحق المدنيين في قطاع غزه فيما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي تنفيذ عمليتين بريه وبحريه ضد
مقاتلي حماس وكتائب القسام تؤكد تصديها
لمحاوله انزال اسرائيليه عند شاطئ رفح
جنوبي
القطاع وعلى سبيل الانتهاكات الانسانيه
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه يقول انه
لم يتبقى في المنظومه الصحيه في القطاع اي
مستشفى قادر على تقديم خدماته والانروا
تؤكد انها لن تكون قادره على استكمال
العمل من دون تامين الوقود وبرنامج
الاغذيه العالميه يحذر من امكانيه توقف
مخابز عن العمل
وعلى صعيد التحرك الدولي مفاوضات متسارعه
للاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار وانجاز صفقه
تبادل بين حماس واسرائيل بوسطه قطريه
وواشنطن تطلب من اسرائيل التعامل بشكل
افضل مع قضيه الرهائن والوضع الانساني في
غزه في حين ان باريس تؤكد على ضروره ضمان
وصول المساعدات
الى
اللقاء y